well we're joined now in the studio by
the house secretary
matthew hancock thank you very much for
being with us good morning
difficult few days for all of us i'm
sure and before we get
on to the wrestling interview i just
want to play you a clip of the prime
minister
this is from wednesday
we don't want to as i say to
to ban christmas to uh to cancel it
uh and i i think that would be frankly
inhuman and
against uh the instincts of many people
in this country
why has the prime minister now imposed a
policy that just four days ago
he said would be inhuman well we don't
want to do any of this
but it's necessary i mean this has been
an
awful end to what has been an incredibly
difficult year
and on friday when we were presented
with that
new scientific evidence about the new
variant
it was our duty to act and and
you know from being presented on friday
afternoon
with the uh with the just the strength
of how easy
this new variant finds it to
transmit from one human to another um
we acted very quickly and decisively
and with the announcements that the
prime minister
set out yesterday and you know i just
think
everybody watching will will feel this
sense that we both feel of uh a
disappointment
uh and that it's just so difficult ahead
of
christmas which everybody was really
looking forward to
after all of the sacrifices that have
been made but unfortunately
this virus the new strain was
out of control we've got to get it under
control
and the way that we can do that the only
way you can do that is by restricting
social contact and essentially
especially in tier four areas
everybody needs to behave as if they
might well have the virus and that is
the way that we can
get it under control and keep people
safe i think people understand
the reasons behind the restrictions i
guess the question perhaps some have is
the way that it's been done so close to
christmas and you're saying of course
that you only found out the full
information about the new strain
on friday but at the same time so the
chief medical officer said yesterday
you know there's no current evidence to
suggest the new strain causes a higher
mortality rate
or that it affects vaccines and
treatment so all that's changed
is that it transmits more easily yes and
i understand that you didn't know about
the new strain
but back in november on the 24th of
november when you announced the
christmas relaxation
it was entirely predictable that the
virus might be spreading more quickly
than you thought at the time
so why did you make that promise all the
way back then and get everyone's hopes
up
uh no in november the uh thankfully the
numbers of cases was coming down
and i understand they're coming down in
november but you could have predicted
that they might be going back up again
in four weeks time this is extremely
unpredictable virus
well as you say it's very unpredictable
and why did you make that promise
well it's very unpredictable because we
understand i understand
how important christmas is uh to people
and who've been looking forward to it
all year and uh and
you know in in thankfully in many parts
of the chris of the
country it is going to be possible to
have a
restricted very careful uh christmas
break essentially on christmas day
itself but the whole challenge of
dealing with this
this pandemic has been that being
unprecedented
we've had to learn about the virus all
the way through
and then we've got this new variant
which the scientists are
still learning about i mean you know
even today they're
doing more research on it to understand
more and what matters is that
you know as a society we need to
stop this new variant from spreading and
we can only do that
not just with action by government and
sometimes you know these debates sound
like
it's what is the government going to do
of course we've got an important role
and we act that's why we acted so fast
yesterday
but it's what is everybody going to do
because it's
only if we all take personal
responsibility
to act in a way that doesn't spread the
virus that's the only way that we can
get this new strain under control
i just want to come back to the point
about why you announced christmas
relaxation a month
before it was going to happen because
you say that it was because you you know
care about christmas you know how
important it is but surely it's the hope
that's worse isn't it
you know people have been preparing they
bought the turkeys they've got through
the last few weeks thinking at least i'm
going to see my nan on christmas day
and now the last minute that's been
ripped away i understand the new variant
is here
but it was entirely predictable that the
situation would have changed
in four weeks time so why did you make
the promise when you must have known
there was a chance
you might not have be able to deliver it
well because we've got to balance these
different things that
people all of us want right
well we made a commitment
not knowing of course we didn't know in
the same way that you didn't know sophie
that there was going to be a
new variant that spreads so much faster
which we found out about we found out
the about the existence of it
last weekend and then we found out about
this this
this uh property it has the fact it
spread so much easily
uh so much easier we found out about
that on friday
so i i understand how um
how people are feeling and i feel it you
know i had
i had to call my mom last night and say
you know we're not going to see each
other over christmas
um and because of this new strain it is
a
it is a really very very serious
situation that we all find ourselves in
and we've got to come through it
together but as
as uh dr nagpur was saying the
the good news is that there's light at
the end of the tunnel
and the good news is that the vaccine
rollout is going uh
is going well and it's accelerating and
we're vaccinating more and more people
all of the time so we can see the way
through this but it is going to be a
difficult few months between now and
then
you've been talking about how the new
sprain strain spreads a lot more easily
is there a concern that you know the
current measures that we're taking to
protect ourselves two meters social
distancing face masks
are not going to be enough well what
matters is that
the the new rules restrictions that
we've brought into place
this morning what really matters is that
people not only follow them
but everybody in a tier 4 area acts
as if you have the virus to stop
spreading it to other people
so the the advice on for instance the
two meter rule is that it is
uh that that's that is we should
continue with the two
meter rule um but we just know that this
new variant
you can catch it more easily from a
smaller amount of the
virus being present so it'd be less
effective face masks social distancing
effectively less effective all of the
different measures that we have in place
we need more of them to control the
spread of the new variant than we did to
control the spread of the old variant
that's the fundamental problem and we
know that
because we know that in november in the
areas where this
new variant started in kent the case is
carried on rising whereas in the rest of
the country the november lockdown worked
very effectively and you know in parts
of northern england
the rates have come down really sharply
and yesterday the prime minister said
the new
variant is up to 70 percent more
transmissible than the old variant
um my colleague sam coates has seen
minutes from the sage meeting on
thursday though
the government scientific advisors that
says the extent of any increase in
transmissibility
is not yet known so that's right what's
the 70 figure based on them
so that was new analysis that was
presented on friday
um and this just shows how fast the
scientists are working
and they're doing incredible work you
know one of the reasons we know about
this strain is because of the
incredible scientific work and the
genomics in particular
because many other countries around the
world
may have this strain or something
similar to it but there's only a couple
of other places where we know it exists
where they also have the sort of
genomics
well for instance there's been a case in
in australia
on some parts of continental europe
right but it doesn't take away from the
actions that we all need to follow
here in order to get this under control
if it is 70 more transmissible
that's pretty bleak that's bad well it's
an enormous
challenge until we can get the vaccine
rolled out to protect people
and that's the this is what we face over
the next
couple of months yes um you also said
yesterday at the press conference
that there's no current evidence to
suggest the new strain causes a higher
mortality rate
my question though is you know we only
just found out about this new strain
around a week ago you only got the
evidence on transmissibility on friday
we can't possibly know yet can we if it
does cause
higher mortality well they have looked
into this because
there's over a thousand of these cases
that have been identified over that
period of time in the last
um uh just over a week since the new
variant was identified
and brought to ministers attention and
so they can then
look at the the impact of those of the
disease on those people
there's a lag isn't there between
catching the disease and becoming ill
and sadly dying but because of the high
quality surveillance
that we have they've been able to go
back and find old cases
and then track what happened to those
people so we have a
degree of confidence in that uh outcome
and i think you have susan hopkins on
your program later
because she's the lead expert on this
and and and she'll be able to explain
exactly why we have confidence in in
that outcome could it be milder
there's no evidence of that either sadly
okay that's disappointing but definitely
worth
asking the question yes um now there
will be a review of these tier 4
restrictions
on the 30th of december you were saying
though that t3
didn't slow the spread of this new
variant in kent
so we you know in reality we people
in tier 4 restrictions they're not going
to be coming out of tier 4 anytime soon
are they
well we've really got to get this under
control and
the cases in the tier 4 areas as you've
seen from the graphs that have been
presented have absolutely rocketed in
the last
few a few days last two weeks or so
and so we are we've got a we've got a
long way to go to sort this
essentially we've got to get that
vaccine rolled out to keep people safe
to prepare ourselves
i mean is it likely that if you're in a
tier 4 area now you're going to be in a
tier 4
area until that vaccine is rolled out
well i think that given
how much faster this new variance
spreads
it is going to be very difficult to keep
it under control until we have the
vaccine rolled out
and other parts of the country are
likely to go into tier 4 too
well one of the reasons that we brought
in very strict travel restrictions
saying you
shouldn't leave a tier 4 area you should
stay at home
is to try to prevent this from spreading
across the rest of the country
and indeed to other parts of the world
that don't already have it
and you know we're trying to protect the
rest of
the rest of the country because
obviously under the old variant the tier
three restrictions were working and you
can see that in in
in several parts of the of of england
um and um we so we want to
try to restrict the spread of this as
well as of course stopping it from
spreading in the areas where it's
already rife
you're talking about the importance of
not traveling many of us will have seen
those images
of people leaving london i think we
might be able to
show some as well i mean look at the
packed stations there yeah
what would you say to people who did
travel well this was clearly totally
irresponsible behavior
um the the chief medical officer was
absolutely clear that people should not
should unpack their bags if they have
them packed um
i i'm i i think that it's relatively
small numbers
and the large vast majority of people
throughout this whole pandemic
have followed the rules been responsible
and played their part and i
i want to thank everybody for doing that
it is more important than ever that
people
are responsible not only stick to the
rules but even within the rules
restrict social contact as much as is
possible
because this is this is deadly serious
and you've heard from
the british medical association just now
the impact on
hospitals especially in east london and
in
southern parts of essex and in northern
kent
and we're also seeing the impact sadly
in the figures
the number of people who are dying each
day
this is a deadly disease we've got to
keep it under control and it's just been
made more difficult by this new variant
if infections continue to rise
will you consider closing schools well
schools are closed for the next few
weeks and the education secretary is set
out
they're due to reopen well that's a few
weeks
hence the education secretary set out
the
how we're planning to reopen schools
using testing to reduce the spread
and so there's an awful lot of work
going on and i'm very grateful for all
of the teachers and admin staff at
schools who are working over christmas
to get those proposals in
but just to be clear if infections
continue to rise
could you consider asking schools to
move to online learning
well the the education secretary set out
the plans for the
uh for schools in january and because of
testing and because we know the tests
work on this new
variant we're able to
we've got plans to keep schools open
that are
essentially in a way that can
stop them from transmitting the virus by
using very extensive testing in schools
just quickly would you consider
recalling parliament to vote on the
rules
well the rules are already in place uh i
was i got the question though
retrospective vote well there will be a
vote in parliament on these rules
yes uh in january but obviously having
taken the decision on
saturday lunchtime and brought it into
force
earl in the early hours of this morning
the we didn't have time to recall
parliament
from the point of decision at uh two
o'clock yesterday afternoon
when cabinet concluded uh in support of
these measures
before implementing in the early hours
of this morning
and therefore there will be a vote uh
after the fact when parliament comes
back in january
um we touched on vaccines a bit earlier
in the interview but it does feel like
it's worth asking again because it's
such a
something that all of us are clinging to
like there have been some concerns about
the speed
of the vaccine rollout though it was
said that we'll have to double the rate
at which we're rolling the fires of
acting out if you want to vaccinate all
vulnerable people
and key workers by easter a thing is
going to ramp up and how far
away are we from approving the oxford
vaccine
well um i feel i'm able to smile for the
first time
uh in uh several days the um uh the
the the are are accelerating and rising
fast the numbers that we're vaccinating
can you give us some new numbers then to
give us
well as of 8 o'clock yesterday morning
350 000 people have been vaccinated
uh we plan by the end of the weekend
to have something around the half a
million mark i'm not going to
put a that's not a target that's an
estimate um
and we're vaccinating more and more
people each day
we've now got over 400 different sites
that are vaccinating whereas at the
start of last week we only had 100 so
that's a multiple of four
so you can see that there is a
significant acceleration in the plans
some people have seen the total number
that have been vaccinated and
extrapolated that in a straight line
that's the wrong thing to do
because all the time every day we're
opening more and more vaccination
centers we're bringing more and more of
the gp led centers
on stream and how far away is the oxford
vaccine from approval
well that's a matter for the mhra the
regulator could it happen before
christmas
after christmas what's the uh it's very
tempting but i'm
just not going to speculate because i
respect their independence and that
includes
their independence to choose the timing
of any announcement
i need to ask you about brexit but just
very quickly if you knew
your neighbours for example breaking the
rules at christmas would you call the
police
well i just think it's so important that
every single person
follows these rules so would you call
the police well i think everybody should
follow the rules
and i don't think that's what i'm saying
it does but it but it needs saying
sophie because it's so important in this
in this
pandemic okay running out of time and i
do need to talk about brexit of course
just 11 days
until the end of the transition period
what state are the talks in how
confident are you that there'll be a
deal
well i i think the talks are continuing
um
i understand that the eu have put in a
deadline of having them concluded by
christmas
we want these talks to reach a positive
conclusion of course i want a deal
i think everybody wants a deal
unfortunately the eu have put in some
unreasonable demands
and i just you know obviously i've been
mostly concentrating on the pandemic but
i have been
looking at the detail of some of the
requests from the eu
they're unreasonable uh they they do not
respect the result of the referendum
what in particular is unreasonable well
over the uh the
sovereignty of our rules uh around
at the so-called level playing field
actually this is
rules around how uh how government
introduces subsidies
and then overfishing you know so i'm
sure that a deal can be done
but obviously it needs movement on the
eu side
and i'm i'm an incredibly pragmatic
politician and
you know i want to see a deal but i also
think
that the eu demands are unreasonable and
they're not demands that
that can can be accepted so we do need
to see that movement from the eu
side and i very much hope that they make
the steps that are necessary so that we
can
we can we can conclude a deal and then
we can all
look forward you know um with uh and
and we've got a huge amount to get
through as a
as a continent uh you know because there
are very significant problems with this
virus on the on the continent as well of
course we're seeing cases rise in
many continental countries so so let's
just
you know they need to make the move they
need to remove some of the unreasonable
requests and then we can all
move forward and concentrate on dealing
with the things that are
right in front of us the urgent action
the eu parliament set a deadline of
tonight do you think there's any chance
the deal will be done this weekend
well i don't know but i think we should
keep talking and we should come to a
deal and
i think that um it's that it's just so
important that the eu side uh
makes the changes that are needed to be
able to get a deal and otherwise
we're ready for an australian type
outcome if that's what's necessary
no deal welcome well we've already got
we've already got the withdrawal
agreement
and that deals with the whole problem no
further
we're ready for that act that's not an
outcome i wish to see
but we're absolutely ready for it and uh
but i hope that we get the movement from
the eu that we need
okay matt hancock we're out of time
thank you very much for being on the
program this morning thank you